they're the deadliest thing on earth
they suck your blood and spread disease
killing nearly 1 million people each
year
we're talking about mosquitoes it may
sound unusual that a little bug could be
this deadly but it's true mosquitoes
spread diseases like malaria yellow
fever and the Dengue virus
they do it by biting someone who has a
particular disease and then biting you
and injecting their saliva into your
body
the saliva then enters your bloodstream
causing you to contract whatever virus
or bacteria that the mosquito picked up
animals and farm livestock all around
the world suffer greatly from mosquitoes
just a single bite can be fatal